estas personas son las últimas en
embarcan en el último vuelo civil de
francia para salir de afganistán
alrededor de 60 personas principalmente
afganos y algunos ciudadanos franceses
salieron del aeropuerto de kabul a
última hora del viernes francia ha
evacuado unas 3.000 personas desde que
los talibanes tomaron el control el 15
de agosto en un comunicado las
autoridades anunciaron el fin de su
operación de rescate pero prometieron
seguir esforzándose para ayudar a los
que aún están en el país a salir por
otros medios
mira reino unido- también puso fin a sus
evacuaciones de civiles el sábado miles
de afganos siguen reuniéndose frente al
aeropuerto sin importar el riesgo de
otro ataque y con disparos de
advertencia para dispersar a la multitud
que intenta desesperadamente huir este
agua no lleva dos semanas escondido en
kabul y aún tiene la esperanza de subir
a un avión
hong kong donde corremos mucho peligro
nos amenazan los talibanes volvieron a
entrar en nuestra casa pero nos
escondimos por suerte quiero estar en
francia donde estaría a salvo y podría
mantener a mi familia a salvo también
él es uno de los muchos que han
trabajado con el ejército francés y no
han conseguido ir con esta abogado que
representa a los intérpretes a planos
hemos conseguido identificar a unos 100
por el momento que siguen esperando
llamadas porque sus solicitudes no han
sido válidas porque el ministerio de
defensa tiene que validar cada vez sus
perfiles para comprobar que han
trabajado para el ejército francés pero
también hay muchos cuyas solicitudes ya
han sido válidas pero no han conseguido
subir a los últimos vuelos franceses
eeuu anunció que había llevado a cabo un
ataque con drones contra un objetivo del
estado islámico en el este de afganistán
matando a dos de sus líderes el ataque
del grupo yihadista en el aeropuerto de
kabul el jueves ha complicado las
evacuaciones y ha añadido más presión en
una situación ya tensa